ultime répétition du carnaval des
animaux pour ces jeunes élèves de faille
aux loges jolie un joli double à cette
fantaisie zoologique côtoient pour la
première édition du festival
les spectacles interprétés par des
acteurs de renom comme robin renucci
c'est important ou deux de se dire qu'il
y avait des compagnies professionnelles
qui viennent de france
peu importe voilà est aussi
naturellement des compagnies de la
région centre et donc entre autres sur
les 8 10 spectacles il y a trois
compagnies de la région centre c'est
important ça aussi de vivre jouer et
travailler au pays
créer un festival à la campagne c'est le
pari que se sont lancé les habitants de
faille aux loges petite commune bordés
par le canal d'orléans le maire et
professeur de chant alors nous on s'est
dit qu'il n'était pas pour rien tout est
venu d'un événement malheureusement un
peu tragique les inondations de 2016 où
il ya eu un élan de générosité de
d'entr'aide de vivre ensemble très
important et on s'est dit que ça serait
intéressant de profiter en quelque sorte
de ceux de cet engouement général pour
mettre ça au service d'une d'une action
d'une action en l'occurrence le festival
et c'est ici dans cette ancienne usine
électrique que se joue ce week end
l'étranger d'albert camus ou encore le
spectacle de danse du chorégraphe
abderzak houmi et puis à une encablure
de là dans la salle des fêtes
en fin de festival pour boucler il y un
spectacle de ouf
vraiment ça s'appelle brainstorming il
n'y a pas un mot c'est que du visuel
c'est buster keaton c'est mon petit
piton c'est vraiment un truc qui
déménage joué par une compagnie de lyon
on file à tour sur la scène du petit
faucheux
elle donne carte blanche samedi soir
autres moniste fidel fourneyron
l'artiste en résidence à monter tout
exprès un orchestre avec neuf musiciens
pour revisiter la musique cubaine et ses
chants traditionnels
[Musique]
samedi c'est aussi la nuit des musées 65
établissements de la région ouvrent
leurs portes pour la soirée
l'occasion de découvrir des lieux
insolites comme ici la maison pique
assiette à chartres ou encore d'aller au
musée de la marine de loire de
châteauneuf près d'orléans pour voir
l'exposition rétrospective de l'oeuvre
du caricaturiste andré milan
[Musique]
dimanche concert matinal à l'abbaye de
noirlac dans l'indre avec l'ensemble
vocal baltes la viande voices et leur
répertoire les tons folk qui puise aussi
dans des compositions plus contemporaine
le spectacle a cappella intervient à
11h30 après une conférence sur la
publicité au moyen-âge
jeudi 24 mai lagence cycliques et le
cinéma les lobbies ablo à programme une
soirée spéciale court métrage quatre
histoires fantastiques dont l'une acide
a été tourné à sainte maure de touraine
et à cravans les coteaux en indre et
loire
bon week-end à tous
deux suisses commencent à nous